hey guys it is Wednesday I'm Jessica and
I'm Daniel and let's never say awful
names again agreed sometimes just
knowing a little bit of something just
keeps the mystery alive are you making a
very vague reference to our story of the
day oh I am roll those credits as e3
draws closer giant billboards and
posters have started popping up all over
LA and a particular date of war poster
appears to be missing a very interesting
section Twitter use a monkey flop my
kingdom for a normal internet username
posted this photo of a God of War poster
on Twitter it shows the original emo
Kratos along with the unnamed boy seen
in last year's reveal trailer the new
god of war was announced at e3 last year
and is set after the events of the third
game it won't feature an open world or
any multiplayer or the original Kratos
voice actor but I'm sure there are lots
of things it does feature so stay tuned
to e3 let us know in the comments below
if you're excited for the return of God
of War it looks like we're headed to
Egypt in the next Assassin's Creed if
the latest leaked image is to be
believed man I'm so thirsty over on
neogaf user a silent protagonist posted
an image of a target pre-order card for
the gold edition of Assassin's Creed
origins man first the gold ps4 now this
target loved linking gold stuff this
year wait let me rephrase that the
pre-order card shows a hooded character
complete with a gold shield and a pet
eagle in front of a pyramid and what
definitely looks like the space it also
says to reserve now for a bonus mission
secrets of the first pyramids so it's
pretty safe to say it looks like we'll
be heading to Egypt we're expecting to
see and hear much more about the next
Assassin's Creed at ubisoft's III press
conference on Monday June 12th at 1:00
p.m. we'll be streaming all the press
conferences and bringing you
up-to-the-minute coverage so make sure
you are subscribed so you don't miss a
thing
Hideo Kojima has come out with an update
on death strandings presence at e3 and
it's it's not gonna be there
I don't allege one to pad out this story
I'm going to recite some selected a
Okajima tweet or just gives you the
details
Kojima announced via Twitter that death
stranding will be skipping III as the
team is fully focused on development
came home exhausted
I opened Godzilla the plays the theme
song but had no batteries 53 year old
man shall just cry instead in me
9 well that's a bit of a bummer he did
follow that up with this cryptic picture
adding the caption here's the only new
information I can present at this time
the story reminds me of war buddies in
mother base as minions go look for the
strongest and worst Big Boss Hideo
Kojima is closer to appear at Jeff
Kelly's TV series III Coliseum
so speculate away while Dan reads you
out the final excellent kijima tweet egg
Benedict looks like boobies when shaking
the plate Walt is everything we've got
for you today do let us know what you
thought of today's stories in that
comment box and don't forget to grab the
games for now app on iOS and Android 4
completely free that will give you the
top 10 news stories of the day deliver
it right to your phone we'll see you
guys later